hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to turbo dismount now
I'm doing an intro this time and I don't
normally do this because there is a lot
of new features that were put in since
the last time that I played it has been
a while since I played there's new
people as it poses there's new maps new
splats new things I don't really know
what's new but I know that this guy's
new he's got a little bit of a belly
going on here good god I'm so sorry he's
dead
screw everything up what's the worst
that could happen as you're weaving in
and out of the road the most pathetic
player that is a confident pose sir that
seems pretty typical I don't even know
what you're doing hey do you like one of
your french girls they're gonna paint
you all the road in the second ear that
is really fast way to go man you're
racing he's racing this is it
why can't I crash anymore I seem to have
deposited myself outside of my car could
someone come help me just a little help
is all that I need they said that this
one was actually you got to you did get
to I get to steer it oh my god I wait
haha you didn't tell me how this does
not help me at all that my body so Oh
ding ding um I ate a lot of ice cream
oh my mommy and daddy aren't you mad at
me stealing from the ice cream store
Oh God I hope my mommy and daddy know
what I'm doing right now because I'm
doing a handstand on the highway that's
not very safe
Oh goddamn it doesn't matter at all okay
it seems said my balance just okay if I
can make it to the cops
I'm so sorry it was a baby both of us
okay I need something a little bit
sturdier wow you're very flexible it's
so weird to see my face on that body
oh man that's what I'm I look like 20
years oh yeah I think my problem is that
I'm not in the vehicle I need to be in
to be braum Brian I'm coming for you
coppers late left right whatever you
know the direction I'm talking about
the counter parties Evelyn my head is
gone
you'll never take me alive coppers this
is my exit Oh run the wrong line Oh God
wrong lane what'd I do
turn right little small adjustments what
are you doing that bus stopped at me
stop it grilled version of me stop
humping that bus hi what are you hump to
your heart's content I really can't stop
what are you what are you doing it's
working your nipples why don't you have
better things to do like making it up
this okay hey you know what I just make
it okay it crumbled to pieces
you broke the buggy bus it's dad now you
big dumb brute no don't don't you sass
me go are ye your lip you make it up
that hill all the way all the way don't
you dare think about stopping oh you
dare come or do you oh so you don't even
wanna crash everybody hang on I have an
idea and when mark has an idea you know
things are about to go terribly wrong oh
oh you like to hump do you oh boy you
know as I said in signs hump away
Papa wake Bryan oh you're fine how are
you fine
how are you still humping what is it
possible you totally lost one arm yeah
yeah yeah that's a three hang you see
you so good easy tight buns any splits
I'll show you a good time
oh you think you're so strong with your
chest thrust that would forget what I
got a little present for you called over
nine foul how are you alive
this is ridiculous I've blown up every
other person that has worked for me in
totally ok I will ignore that because
that wasn't a very big kid but this Oh
screw you and your face better die at
the bottom of this how are you missing
things how are you missing things
where are you invincible it doesn't make
any sense
oh no it's just a mine well oh I'm so
sorry I
oh oh so sad I apparently can't remove
steering as an option so I'm stuck with
it for now so there
oh oh I'm beautiful this isn't gonna
work out for me at all is it I don't
even come on it was basic power all
right try it again with a little more
it's happy thrust is
okay oh my god that was glorious oh I'm
so pretty like an elegant butterfly
until right about here and then I get
bounced back and forth like a toy ball
BAM
Oh God bye that's a one a speed Jesus
got obliterated you work that big old
behind thinks he looks a bit like an ant
but okay I can't go an episode without
doing the token bird of course I can't
but God why you have to be so creepy
whatever you do don't die maybe because
you shift your balance it'll be hit you
directly in your face
okay I'll end on that note there's a lot
more turbo dismount to be discovered
still I still not have tried out every
combination of the people in the poses
and I'm sure there's a lot more laughs
to be asked so thank you all so much for
watching if you have an idea of what
level you want me to play or if you have
made me a level and want me to play it
in turbo dismount let me know in the
comments below thanks again everybody
and as always we will see you in the
next video